hello three of them listeners lauren lacus
here okay so last week we played
a meme that we could not stop
laughing at um and since then we
have learned that the guy in the
meme is like an amazing musician his
name is brushy one string he plays
a guitar with one string by the
way and that songs stuck in my
head for the past week you need
to go
to his kickstarter page google brushy one
string and kickstarter and you will find
it he is trying to raise ten
thousand dollars for his new album and
i think combined we can all help
him get there really quickly so go
donate a dollar or two and see
what happens this is exciting he's he
brought us so much joy in that
last episode and and online for a
whole week after so please support him
okay
thanks so much for ah who's there
it's through them oh it's rid of
it i am three am but it
is
them three to mow them freedom boys
are all by weird we are entertain
y'all hear them three boys is coming
to town
oh do it yay them boys don't
come downtown gonna make a big game
don't make a big stake make a
big stake and the freedom boys ooh
i got some coffee i'm gonna take
it hey welcome to freedom i've got
some coffee and i'm gonna drink it
i call it i'm gonna drink it
sorry oh la la i gotta go
i mean i'm laundering it i guess
i'm doing guys know me and i'm
gonna get more and laugh guess i
guess what i mean
laundering
i am wondering if i'm poor i
guess i got in there yeah hi
everyone welcome to the show wow is
your day please respond in this silence
great good good good fan by the
way if you have a remix of
our theme song please send it to
yeah wait that one was great and
we'd love to hear another one enter
somebody tanner was for two nights lucas
tanner i had a roommate to four
six one two four six so wow
taylor
anyone we need manner what did he
do he was in theater school with
me and he was a great guy
he was my roommate and he had
a weird thing where he was only
cast in non human parts the entire
time he was in school so he
was a he was like one of
the he was the monkey and wizard
of oz he was all monkey
yeah well there was you could only
afford like the mail for exchange production
me monkey and a thousand standing behind
you
on your site
and then he was a cow and
into the woods and then he was
a demon and jesus christ superstar can
you look up the monkeys from wizard
of oz like the ridge but where
are they now
you just wanna see what they look
like yeah cause like i'm kind of
like not remembering ah didn't say the
last person who was alive and in
wizard of oz just died is that
true oh so your entire film they
were people in wax and like yeah
things yeah yeah because in my mind
i kind of thought it was a
rolling masks and hidden things
i remember the monkeys really creepy me
out but only on the third time
i watched it because they used to
you know play it once a year
when i was a kid on cbs
i think but for whatever reason like
a holiday or no just like this
is the time of yeah we play
wizard of oz they would do that
with certain movies like the day of
three channels oh yeah kind of
like that a lot yeah i will
say the candle thing like i was
also thinking about the other day about
how how advertising how easy it was
back then you just put on a
tv commercial and everyone in the world
would see it yeah yes you know
and mean and now i was watching
commercials the other day and i was
like gonna reference something when i was
talking to cool up and i was
like who knows if she's even seen
this commercial because
she's not watching the particular right thing
that i'm watching you know what i
mean yeah but um she also probably
have been more yeah well and getting
been bored the other day you guys
have separate room to watch tv any
day now i she i we were
both catching up on a show and
she i got really tired i went
to bed i'm really tired
went camp and i i think she
stayed up to like two in the
morning and watched six or seven more
episodes it called veronica minor my god
with kirstie alley i love bachus and
her closet huh oh my god can
we see the opening theme to that
too
was was okay didn't have an opening
theme it must have had something every
show did back then well no that
was around the time when they were
they were stopping that practice yeah there's
wylie lang
oh okay it was this song oh
shit oh my god she's like modeling
and all victoria secret model dan cuenta
jays oh my god
wally langham crazy alley was so beautiful
she was i loved her so much
and i had a gigantic crush on
her and cheers i loved her chances
buying she's so beautiful and funny and
lucas and jimmy hilarious so named jimmy
is olive there's a thing by the
way drawing love this opening this is
new
huh huh
they had to oh really go but
they all hated each other to like
you know how like please them since
friends for the friends were the only
friends who actually made friends yeah the
show creators you know but like in
the history of television well i think
so only know usually there's like one
person that everyone in the cast dislikes
likes isn't it there i think
it's often the case that's the most
looking like a will and grace they
all love they'll probably love it yeah
have a great time look at bajillion
dollar product but then they make these
when he pulled the dance around
they may know his answer i don't
like like high early yeah early on
and they probably all hate each other
but they're all goofing around and laughing
know like they don't hate each other
yet they probably all actually do don't
think hey no other way like episode
ten and then they're like watching this
opening my dad if any of you
were on veronica's closet please let us
know if you all hate it
each other i would like to know
yeah there's this thing i want to
talk about this because in the credits
i guess the comedic character danced around
and then fell and it was supposed
to be funny like she tripped and
fell okay so here's something that i've
been noticing and i was watching ah
what's that cbs show love island and
the host of that
does this thing where it's like where
you have you cast someone and jenny
mccarthy was the first person to do
this as i recall you cast someone
who's as hot as a model but
then and then she does what a
model does like like blowing her hair
and doing a slow motion walk but
then she trips yeah yeah or yeah
and that's funny
three thousand just like why yeah i
and that's funny it's the tiredness thing
it's also like an a lot of
rom coms you'll see this like breath
rolling comedy for ya that are more
broad like will feature like a super
hot lady just falling down multiple teri
hatcher and desperate housewives that's i think
she did it a few times really
and that and then it became like
rebecca romain and her pilot she was
like fall fell into a trash can
because it's like being like i love
lucy or something it's like no not
really you also have to like be
funny yeah yeah you can't just fall
into a trash can like you be
funny right now i fall into a
trash can
you just stay there but it's it's
very hey this is my home number
it's like oh my god
it's annoying that it's it's still happening
like it's still still happening and people
are based fine with it it's basic
they're fine with it because the person
doing it is hot yeah csgo on
their hot chairs like you just don't
care i find myself i guess i'm
the one watching nurse yeah i'm the
one watching love island instead of a
real comedy so i guess
it is you know i've i i
love sorry is it supposed to be
a comedy no no no but they
but they they they tried to be
funny no they well the the narrow
okay so here's like comedy here's what
i could glean from it because it's
very popular infused humor it's very poor
oversee use it's very popular overseas but
there's a scottish area
island yeah there's like you're watching the
u k version no no i'm watching
the u s but from what i
could understand from what i read is
there in the u k version there's
a scottish guy he sounds older sounds
like ferguson he's like oh why did
you do the dough boy who everyone
thinks is very very funny oh look
out don't fall down yeah yeah yeah
stewie attractive so that guy
oh right you haven't seen it no
it actually is really accurate so in
this version that american's funny his video
yeah he just makes tough shit over
it it is yeah so in this
version they they cast a new person
and it's a comedy
who is doing the voice now two
two seven is a comedy yeah i
know two two seven is a comedy
so i think they cast someone who's
not a comedian but he's household and
any sounds like he's reading written stuff
you know in a way so ah
but but they they've gone for sort
of more of ah like a guy
dishing on stuff
the kind of thing like this is
like here's someone here's the other thing
that i don't like about anytime anyone
on the show gets a text he
goes sand which i think is gabe
ah lehman's thing oh do you feel
like sure there's they're ripping them off
yeah that actually it's been somebody receives
a text or someone sends it someone
on the show receives a tax they
have to make a big deal of
it
out of it and go off i
gotta tell everybody they might do that
in the old one because it the
premise is like that the narrator is
sending them that yes but he's he's
saying it he'll retail read it a
lot and then say so no no
no no the narrator says speaking of
which i have something for these people
sand i have to look at the
epo
you want to see okay see if
he says said yeah because i feel
like people are boom i think people
are ripping off games i would think
that a lot these days yeah it's
almost like richard louis you know what
people started doing send tweet yes if
that was not exactly exactly the same
on let's cap off gabe don't rip
well it's richard lewis from hell from
hell he was the first person in
his act to ever say from hell
like this is the thing from hell
i was like everyone would laugh just
at him saying the she's the girlfriend
from hell just wow that was really
funny to people he invented that he
invented it good and sound like it
does nothing now because it's so it's
everyone
jones said it and his basic yeah
it's become basic oh wow to create
something you know what's so amazing this
woman you see online um the woman
who in like created the gender reveal
party did you oh ya no i'm
laughing because i thought of a thing
too late to say in response to
oh say right now we'll edit it
in bulk
yeah so we make the show yeah
that's how we any day so we
always like three days later come back
to the studio well people don't realize
there's a lot of post production i
just go like chicken going down so
so set me up again you know
so amazing you know what's so amazing
spider-man yes you know it's so spectacular
spider-man yeah what so friendly neighborhood
did you see ah this woman the
woman who essentially like accidentally created the
gender reveal party how does she act
yeah the first person to do it
and she or you know the first
person to post online or gender reveal
party worked probably had sorts of props
and like three assholes
or like the like you know
the um like you know the different
ways you can reveal it like something
exploding like a k coming something inside
it or whatever oh she posted it
and it became a viral thing and
then people started doing it and she
now says she regrets like she she
didn't have any idea that would become
a big thing but she regrets it
and the girl the baby girl who
was boy
born from the first gender reveal party
prefers to her suits and she basically
was like we shouldn't like start things
out for switch shoots and because mega
mar first that basically she just was
like i regretted kind of watch to
make starting over
or something to matter yeah gender your
baby that's cool sex she invented the
gender reveal party she has some regrets
she's going to this so she is
one of em and then listed like
three other regrets she cheated on her
husband
like look if we're gonna talk about
one of your regrets we gotta talk
about all of them she didn't invest
in apple when she had the chance
goes down a little
did she like so she did the
cake icing inside where oh so basically
looks like a pinterest fail and looks
like a nail kinda go byron it's
really it really looks horrible um it
looks like a weird baby generally the
cake and a gay man paying frosting
gender of your baby king
maybe everybody's a bitter rant everybody's humping
around i mean i thought that was
pretty interesting humping she just was like
this i mean yes matt is having
round around and i did the two
everybody's home at the time because we
didn't live in twenty nineteen and didn't
know what we know now that assigning
focus on gender
what if she lives in one hundred
and tumbling to their potential and talents
that have nothing to do with what's
between their legs short and her oh
man yeah it's cool it's cool it's
kinda nice to have like the person
go hey oops it is it's very
exciting to carry well yeah yeah it's
not like scolding it's just like this
is what i've learned as a fucking
human being on the
plans and posts a picture with her
family and her tower i'll look at
that dog is gonna look at that
oh that little dialogue that dog i
gotta say she's hot the mom yeah
she's gay she's bay i bang her
dewar don't look up this picture and
let us know if you would bang
her and i'm talking about that dog
yeah talk about the dog
ooh that doe da oh yeah yeah
way that dao love bad jig back
by love that with little guys
there are there are low little side
dog there are enough entertainers with weird
voices anymore like doctor john died well
you got dr john you got wolfman
jack but also the guy mr the
guy we were just doing earlier um
budget likely
if you have a funny voice you
should be famous right who's got the
weirdest voice right now yeah i'm trying
to think of anyone any entertainer who
just coasts on a weird voice rudd
aquafina was like pauly shore the last
one
but even he holly sure um but
that was more of an affected manner
of speech well you can't tell me
that kevin has pulled up the most
distinctive voices in hollywood know do like
weird way back jack nicholson hi every
body
oh who has the most annoying voice
what have all three of us come
up
oh shit i'm trying to think i
sort of thought of someone recently where
i was i think putting that on
that had to have been gold when
you discovered like wait a minute i
can do a funny voice no one
else has ever done oh yeah you
know man i wish i could do
one the gilbert god freed and he's
yeah he's someone's putting on no because
then we yeah we saw
or even that bunch of them or
whatever is putting on a thing when
you don't know about their murder or
you think he always talk like me
i think so
i doubt over godfrey and like that
there's like some documentary he's in and
he uses his normal or no yeah
it's actually howard stern clips that i
looked up online but there's a documentary
yeah where he just yeah and there's
regularly no he did bang bang once
he's a normal guy just talk normally
i was like hi gilbert so great
to have you and he's like hi
it's so good yeah that's just
confusing saving them early and then when
he was on the show he was
like yeah why though it must be
tiring to do that yeah of course
yeah make your head hurt i mean
i heard her right now my head
her eric why was bo derek in
their vote very voices and bo dare
oh it what what is
this list what is this list people
want to take their voices oh dear
oh derek i can think of two
things more distinctive than her voice she
should give me a scotch yeah you
know any you think you can pick
her tits out in the lineup i
don't think i'd like to love them
oh i'm a regular guy
one day you'll convince us of that
yeah not today any ah any pot
any pots has a good voice hey
everybody what are you upto bea arthur
michael dorn lynne thigpen shore sure limb
thigpen and godfrey it's eighteen under bo
derek i'm casey kasem and i'm on
saved by the bell iron
casey yes he was i'm on say
by the bill this week what did
he ever won i assume he played
himself yeah not like a detective or
three ham teens well you know what
i realised what type of value my
mentioned is like saved by the bell
is written but was written by like
older white guys who like in the
nineties they were like mariska stouts for
the fifties
and they were like yeah they mess
with the unsay by the bell they
always seem like fifty songs and like
casey case so maybe it's like they
think was like they were really not
hip with the times and like many
things looked right well they did not
care no but that was a weird
give a show that was like f
the end of when fifties nostalgia was
cool because you have the peach pit
on yeah really hills nine
oh to ueno and even when i
was watching i was like these dorks
go to a fifties diner but that's
like because the people writing it yeah
yeah they're all like people who were
fifty when they were right right did
you know whatever age you're in you're
nostalgic for that totally so right now
they'll thirty forty s
oh you're in your happy days period
that's why you're dressed as the boss
today yes look anything like period funds
with a black t-shirt yes um and
to start the theme song you hit
that computer did you guys
thank you i need to be plugged
in my second computer plugged in have
you ever been jacked in a room
inject inject up and checked off
the three jacks um did you want
about me before jack's because you guys
ever do a moon jake's more allies
forget to do things to each other
um did you ever do april richardson
saved by the bell podcast yeah raised
by tv and we talked all about
that's right so is my essence it
was for only time i'd ever watched
that show i watched an episode me
to identify a couple episodes of that
show and i it would make me
mad how shitty a while yeah and
i watched everything is shitty when you're
a kid and you don't know it
i know but i
i was shy well into it and
you don't know well the stuff you
like is all shit you don't realize
how bad it yeah scooby-doo terrible but
i've seen every episode of se but
about a hundred times like i've watched
it up up until start doing raised
by tv and it started to become
not as fun for me anymore it's
a job well became less laying out
with us became less like curling up
with a good
book yeah to watch my shitty shows
and now it feels like hong talked
about it a lot but yeah i
would watch that stuff like just to
make myself feel better like all the
time and like also i was walking
up watching years watches the ah whatever
that bob saget show is full house
yeah cooler know she was four hours
oh try to watch that she'll
watch that just as comfort food yeah
yeah i totally get it yeah i
watch food as comfort food yeah you
watch a steak i'll make up a
big meatloaf and they'll just look at
it do you feel about shows about
food like i don't really get that
excited to know yeah i'll do probably
the only thing that i meet you
yeah i thought that about top chef
i was like look a singing competition
you're hearing beautiful music la la la
la um a dancing show you're watching
beautiful dancing la la la la but
a cooking show you can't taste it
so how but i guess the look
of most people just love looking at
food look of food is so appetizing
and people like to feel how to
cook like
i think some people watch it because
they get tips or getting inspired to
make something or try something but yes
i've learned how to make several amuse-bouche
you know what i like watching it
more vita watch a cooking show is
the top chef junior oh is that
so no yeah maybe i'd try that
when the kids know how to make
something like who yeah i realized the
problem that i have with with shows
like that even like it i remember
oh like a season of top chef
i remember watching a couple seasons of
project runway the problem that i have
with those shows the the the thing
i like about it is people are
making a thing they like they're still
contributing to society well there's there's skilled
people who are who are making something
it's cool and it's going to fountain
him but it's the personalities of the
contestants it's the reality show
aspect of it which maybe they've backed
off of more but a lot of
the people i just found so irritating
i to me hard for me to
watch like the first episode of top
chef where tom kalki like
i didn't know who tom was or
how well-respected he was or whatever so
it was just the very first episode
this guy's kind of smarting off to
him in the very first day or
something in times like get the fuck
outta here and it was just it
was just so like oh shit this
guy you know he's not playing into
it for the cameras easily give me
the respect i deserve to lay that
is and get the fuck out yeah
yeah i'd be so going to it
right now yeah yeah guys alright bye
e o he is running laps e
here where do you get that little
car
at little ford um hi guys turtle
for the new fuller house theme song
no
oh okay
yeah
welcome
oh okay oh oh god
bo bo j
ah gigantic con
oh maybe old people
oh so good it's never unwelcome hey
it's no good agree guys you know
i'm offer only i just got an
email of an offer what am i
here what is this sideway after our
spam call or good conversation i know
five of them like i'm getting so
many if you say
spam your phone picks up early start
calling you but i feel like somebody
like sign me up the series spam
series spammy the series spending my days
spam spammy amadeus on the day of
the game
to click on game i'm a day
as
subject chicken in the cap
the chicken or the gap
oh the chicken in the hook-up chicken
and the gamble oh my spam
ah we've gone insane already on a
name i'm having fun we're just having
fun um we have sick break okay
bye bye
and we're back i like being back
i like it because it's better than
be in front i like being back
yeah that's good i by the way
i like being back i got a
massage the other day speaking back oh
did you somebody much worse stores this
is a week ago mm
my shoulders still hurt from it isn't
that she shouldn't that be what the
massage is curing well you know i
had this thought the other day about
how when i used to get massages
before i ever started working out and
i would get bruised from the massages
and i was thinking i was gonna
groove and be like is it because
i had no matter who whistles it
was like you were going to say
yeah it was like just because it
was so
hard i would leave in like later
i'd have bruises and but it doesn't
have to me now because i'm like
i probably had no muscle like at
all like i don't but is that
a thing will there be more of
who bruise easily i mean a bruiser
yes it is but i don't get
bruised from massages can i poke you
and just see if you yes okay
here you go what does this merchant
of venice i may
oh can i catch you
someone tweeted the student so they say
but whoa weird yeah sorry that i
don't and i was like how do
i say it so it gets a
little bit on crashing i so wanted
to say but hole and crashing who
you said but hole on crashing apparently
i'd love to say buttle and crashing
but why don't you watch something else
weird too
yeah they did they said some other
odd thing oh well yes they did
because this person was telling tagged me
in something that jason zucker said i'm
how did this get about and just
the r word and they said it
was great all right there were so
many things happening i was like leave
me out of this like yeah and
he was talking about he was joking
that i look like the girl from
spiderman three right which haven't we talked
about it on this show i feel
like we talked about you want to
like the girl in spider my main
really your dinah to feel like we
have yeah her name is watches you
said china would jaya
medina tova but but then i was
like i think this girl thought i
really was inspired i tried she didn't
get and shall get jack shit weren't
you in big eyes too yeah i
wasn't big they made a sequel to
big bigeyes because ooh hey wait are
we reviewing it big guys too i'm
going oh
wow she's got big baby she's got
big guys baby buddha arena painting of
corn cobs
what's the most disappointing thing you've ever
seen that you had built up a
lot of anticipation like i was just
needed the mona lisa i can tell
you
i feel like i've talked about it
though oh what can i get a
spanking waiver niche
we stopped the spankings begin i get
we have unfrozen lake creams
hey have i talked about what egg
creams yes and i talked i don't
know what you mean you i think
we have meant yeah yeah i really
want a cream as i read this
book called olaf okay so when i
grew up i grew up in in
suburban orange county california oh where we
sat around by the campfire playing harmonica
hey guys
me
wow and i felt i thought everyone
lived like me other than like maybe
five percent of the population who lived
in a city or whatever you know
or or the one percent of people
in the world who were down on
their luck or whatever but i thought
everett bubbles up because everyone all youth
literature and percent of people who were
down on the but that's that's like
that's literally
the world yeah that's what i mean
is like i just had no conception
because all of you fiction and all
of like movies were e t and
stuff it just was yeah depicting your
depicted mind like the hardy boys you
have a friend you solve mysteries sure
i was living my own choose your
own adventure book i chose it every
day one page sixty two
so so but i read i read
this book called the old neighborhood which
is all about new york city and
about a guy who like grew up
got a got a big important job
but like pine for the old neighbourhoods
so he quits his important job and
started joel song starts his own like
ah not malt shop but like his
own
own corner soda lounge and soda fountain
kind of store because he just loved
a creams and he missed the real
egg cream and i was like oh
my god what if i ever go
to new york i gotta get an
egg creme because no one ever sold
them anywhere in california so we went
to new york when i was twelve
and i insisted on going to a
place and getting an egg creme have
never been more dist
gusted in my life they're disgusting yeah
it's still shocking to hear chocolate syrup
and soda water yeah yeah terrible it's
not good sounds discuss when you hear
a game you think like i don't
know eggs eggs like your eggs are
a chocolate gay you hear that word
cream male and you think that's going
to take care of male cousin joey
james creamy and good cream
cream and egg creme egg cream for
slices do you like shy gerry what
about you paul
yeah and i've built up um i'm
gonna say
it's not the first thing that comes
to mind it's not something that i
had never experienced and then was disappointed
by but something that i had experienced
as a child and was excited to
revisit sang was
you're sick and he is like a
weird sick and when it was new
things you are this is like younger
one you sick of them too weird
scott aquaman strikes again six scholars i
think a weirder man as i tweeted
oh as i
and i instagram tag i'm gonna write
about cold as hell a tweeting and
it's gonna be like oh fucking um
send-up
smooth to me a spoof parody of
eyes i lay dying and he's gonna
be so freaking good it's gonna be
so millennials what i say as i
lay dying i don't know faulkner or
some shit
tell us your story um welcome back
kotter welcome back honor love you as
a child and then it was in
syndication when i was an adult and
i could not believe how terrible it
was yeah i was astonished mister katalor
yeah ev everything and they repeat well
you repeat things that are not funny
if you watch to re success if
you watched it and they didn't say
those things you would be very disappointed
so you know what i mean like
if you watched welcome back kotter one
and you're like oh i hope they
say mr kateri you mean like when
when it was when i was when
it was watching oh yeah yeah yes
but that's like watching us know when
i was fourteen or whatever if eddie
murphy didn't say i'm gumby dammit
or whatever you would go like well
that episode wasn't very good no he
didn't say i'm gumby dammit yeah yeah
and he was in the gumby costume
it was there why wouldn't he say
oh who is he yeah he's just
an extra as gumby in the scene
this some catchphrases like how did they
ever get popular i'm gumby dammit no
one's obvious because that at that time
hadn't been done before to take
children's character and turn nods head and
such nasty little me didn't swear call
me ever what do you have to
know about as he did not sway
on me as one of the tweaks
shows to revisit it's crazy it's so
i don't think i've ever seen it
but it's real drug huey when i
was fourteen i like oh give me
a gumby clip gumby fever was was
like
really popular and nineteen eighty four yeah
so i went out i went out
and got a gumby t-shirts and i
got an actual gumby and pokey and
i had them i think it was
because of eddie murphy wasn't it it
might have been yeah yeah wow that's
so like i wore a gumby shirt
to school and i was young very
excited by it the three shirts that
i can remember being very excited about
were gumby
and we'll all go around the table
of the shirts we were excited gumby
i went out and i had to
find it at a spencer's gifts yeah
and i got it star wars i
got to start i they only had
a small selection of star wars shirts
at mervyn's when i was a kid
and i have the one with luke
and leia shooting and i remember
i wore that to school and everyone
was like oh you're in love with
her because like if you ever brought
a lunchbox or wore a shirt with
a woman on it than you were
in love with her which turned out
to be true sure yes i was
in love with that was unfortunately this
it had a torrid love affair turn
around and then
it's right by me yeah yeah it
actually looks furious at you yeah sure
that's your right turn around me now
i'll never get this lighting just so
i'll never get this lighting just oh
this yousef my third shirt it's not
gonna was it'll try ghostbusters than an
n at dannatt so i got a
shirt that said uh
um it was the phrase from it
damn it i'm ghostbusters
that's right he has no dick it
was something about like back oh back
off man i'm a ghost this one
said back off man i'm a ghostbuster
oh it had the anna and but
to your point several of the kids
were like that's not what they say
in the movie he says back off
man i'm a science but you are
a fool you move who you are
made a fool i just felt
terrible you're laughing sti i was the
livestock of the whole high school gumby
clip
look how druggie this is just got
me he's not well he's coming back
and he's going up into a spaceship
his legs are all blue i feel
like he was sick in this one
dummies flying spaceships like real o g
gumby they go to the moon it's
really why does gumby do this though
like what adventures do the whole episode
what does gumby want
go me on to learn he wants
adventure he wants to discover why you
need to know about gumby god it
scott is it all about his parents
okay nah me his parents are very
absent and they don't realize he's gone
for long stretches of time be lizzy
parents yeah does come to the fucking
moon and his dad finds out by
looking through a telescope what yes scott
just wish i could do watch the
whole series wish i could go to
the moon but my dad looked at
me it's weird finally
yeah i don't want to go to
the moon yes we did i was
the only one want to go i
would never go you never go to
them i don't like going on a
roller coaster and already talked about this
at length i went to start my
really close i went to disneyland the
other day by the way went to
earn that star wars variety yeah thumbs
down oh no why is it so
bad cause it's one of those new
plea
these theme parks stop making boo open
letter open letter yeah open letter c
scott's famous here we go we get
the open letters theme song do a
video here it is yeah
whenever lead you really gotta keep that
open on your phone dan okay
yeah adobe ladder boy ya
every day people
open ah gentlemen gone mad dog dad
mama
ty
and my open letter i am very
angry i'm eddie vedder here's why
nah this isn't play my ukulele this
way eddie if you're there here's a
different open letter eddie i want to
make the show with you an open
letter with eddie better from it
okay so if you're a theme park
and i am i know oh yeah
he's on the moon i know i
know that's obey lauren what do you
seem get into a rocket yeah
i know that space is at a
premium and real estate prices are sky
high even though the fed lowered interest
rates okay alan greenspan
but on stop making these roller coasters
where people just sit in one place
and shaken around while they watch a
video of you moving through stuff you
saying that makes everyone sick yes and
people don't like the harry potter ride
is the most egregious example but to
say that everyone gets sick on it
they had this yeah at the
the first three weeks it was open
every single human being who went on
it threw up and they had to
like tweak it so it was not
as bad but when we went to
holding on on the harry potter ride
you move the the c moves through
the place through a thing you also
are watching videos okay okay but i
want to back up to this yeah
very
old clothes he said every single every
single person every single human being talked
down anyone blah blah blah and they
were counting like that was every guy
with a clicker
but you know anyone and i think
that's a little amount it looks fine
like alright not everyone goes yeah right
on his face he's like oh i
spoke too soon yeah um so it's
like a back to the future one
of those kind of yeah yes the
the star tours was the first one
that i remember ya yas queen where
you sat
around being shaken young not stirred and
then um meanwhile but because the reason
that james bond rides stirs you
which is just it's own brand you're
just like in a big bucket and
then okay like big dick dobson mixes
everybody speaking softly um do you scary
that would be if you were in
like a big gigantic water thing and
like you with a bunch of people
and then a big spoon comes in
and mixes you all up and you're
just spinning and you can't control it
and i don't
oh okay so it's killing me scary
how many mosquitoes have you ever thought
about like if you were suddenly transported
to a different yes ah like alien
world and you were you're as big
as your dogs are are your cats
are in real life and they were
big and they couldn't understand you and
you were like hey hey hey and
that's like barking to them with the
dogs and cats are there check out
would be my god but now there
we've swapped sizes yes the dogs and
catchers because like i'm their pet yeah
and they take care of me they
take care of you because you don't
i mean even though you know and
posable thumbs here's the thing would your
oppose kind of on them
i wonder if you would get to
the point where i honestly would do
everything that'd be fine i would struggle
a giant dogfish they were giving me
food and taking to pee when i
looked like i had to go and
then they would let me curl up
in bed with them at night but
would you want what if you could
understand their language and you know that
they're talking to you like you're a
fucking idiot
i would but they don't understand yours
so but but here's my question though
like if you were transport if you
were like you were taken from mike
you were like kidnap ah your kidnapped
piano know that mike waits outside the
studio yeah everyone thing his watch yeah
give her back
but you were like an ah it's
a total you know clips ah so
very situation i mean what am i
i'm not kidding me too but who's
the vonnegut what's the vonnegut cat's cradle
known cat's cradle slaughterhouse wow yeah slaughterhouse
five thing where you're like you're like
totally transported to a different world but
do you think that you would eventually
grow so dependent on your masters that
you would want to cuddle them like
our dogs do yeah you do you
just miss ko i mean god would
you want to sit him down obi-wan
i feel like if it was just
a world where pets are reversed and
i'm the pet now that's fine but
if it's a world where like i
have a master idol
i mean that's a very different scenario
you're pitching but you know we're like
you do have opposable thumbs in the
entire time you're trying to go hey
there's a mistake why am i have
a life so important ache because yeah
man what's your what are you what
are you fucking obsession with opposable think
that's the reason that dogs and cats
are so dependent on us is because
they can't just open the door i
know but if they were big they
still couldn't
do it they'd be in a world
where opposable thumbs were meaningless i have
six monkeys into raccoons and they can't
do shit without me
your house is filthy but hey because
they will clean it was covered in
monkey swine i get them all they
do is sit around typing all day
yeah she looks like human shit i
hope so
i think all shit looks vaguely to
say ever seen a bird shit the
embassy birgit oh wow it's wide and
slutty
levy okay we have to take a
break we do yeah okay
hi we're back i'm still paul i'm
still loren i'm now paul oh well
my scott no no you're still paul
you said you're assuming we're both sharing
paulino we were sharing the title of
pause is like a doctor who one
of the special episodes i would let
all the guys get together honestly
dead ones i would love it if
when you die and you will die
we'll see if one of our mutual
friends took over
yeah who is who would it be
hodgman or does he already is entrenched
in his mighty stuff i think he's
gone too far into too far and
there was a time there was a
time there's gotta be someone who's more
of a cipher that we know who
could take upon all of the affectations
you guys get scared when you really
think about the fact that you have
no idea when your grand die
i thought about the other day anytime
i see someone who's relatively the same
age as me die i'm just like
man whenever i see crazy i'm like
that could be me
and you're thinking around my works all
the dead people who isn't investigator i'm
haley joel ah yeah oh by the
way it's like one of the nicest
people who so great and by the
way are i get a google alert
for comedy bang gang every day and
i got one the other day and
he still lists it whenever he's cast
in something he's still listed as one
of his main critics
he's like ten episodes he's slow joey
that's nice he's a very good dude
we're we're baseball friends we pleasure you
go to games he goes around into
a game together oh we've we've you
know texted about baseball goes around the
country going to different stadiums yes he
does yes be alright it's time for
three zero everyone it's time for three
char this one comes to us from
tony k at tony kaye at tobar
director of american history x was that
that guy's name i think so wasn't
ah i think this is a different
guy and then tony okay of course
it's okay tony okay what did tonio
k singh from il divo shaven what
did tony okay saying t o n
i okay
k is of course even spelled a
tony space okay no tone t o
n io tony loke space k tonio
joe tony okay sam yeah it looks
like ben stein
when tony okay his money
it looks like i say a lot
on joe guys zines money what if
you won tony okay you love jimmy
kimmel sitting on the safe was he
said nah safe but show me that's
me know you know we know him
from the man show well i knew
it was chaos first thing you know
yeah k rock first yeah yeah his
first tv thing was he was ben
still yeah i remember that
yeah now you do it's a pretty
lord you try to undermine it every
dirt i actually don't it's a pretty
good american success story i'd say like
hey like yeah hello started on the
radio was funny on the radio so
got kasten as a sidekick on a
tv show and radio now he hear
me yes that's what i meant to
say went from being the sidekick to
having one of the most disgusting shows
of all time
yeah i mean to go from a
man show to being like we're talking
about his talk show right
yeah from man show to mount spinner
alright so what is our one my
first job was on jimmy kimmel by
the way you know like what like
maybe my first tv appearance ever i
was on my first sketch with ryan
reynolds really yeah i was doing this
very long sketch with ryan reynolds where
china honestly it was like so great
cause i got to confer with him
for a long time it was like
he has to fire me on behalf
of jimmy kimmel iowa
office and i get really upset i'm
his biggest fan we used to go
we used to go to like at
least once a week to his show
because he had like the greenroom was
a party yeah and everyone was an
open bar and stuff you work out
tarzana cheese what a fun time so
but then they because yes i think
one person was like fuck the fur
first episode someone got too drunk or
whatever so they shut down the open
many people did because they were serving
the audience whoa the show was crucial
was live live and they were serving
the audience boos and it just got
out of hand so fast people would
start yelling and stuff yeah but the
first episode they shut down hollywood boulevard
and coldplay played out in the middle
of the street and so we were
that's
cool is going oh yeah ever want
to be we do we dealt with
this one really that host i did
when i was young and i figured
out through having the band being television
show and just learning more about because
i have friends who have guest hosted
a late night talk show i fell
i figured out that i just wanted
to have a comedy show not be
late because that was the only work
that was the only place that was
doing comedy when i was growing up
is the late night show like letterman
late night yeah so i was i
miss understood and thought oh i wanna
be i wanna have a late night
talk show but what what i really
just wanted to do was have a
comedy show i would love to host
a variety show yes
no one wants me to do it
we should reboot vila variety they're wrong
and you can be johnny blue jeans
i actually i'm can't get into it
i had a couple of friends pitcher
like variety type show that would be
so funny and it got rejected and
i'm like this business is crazy i'm
like this i know this show is
very funny the only way you can
get something like that done as if
you have a massive hit and they'll
just make let you make any yeah
it's it's every every game show is
now
i'm being hosted by like huge celebrities
it's so why is jamie fox host
guys to meet you guys deck sheltered
housing jack schauer get more weight g
nova he's actually everyone has two jobs
jane lynch we have ellen de generous
we have yeah there's another one also
elizabeth banks is same shoe yeah
yes isn't hosting no wagering man i
mean they're all hosted by yeah actors
who are in big movies all the
time yeah let us do shit let
let us comedian do it this is
my plea yeah it's very strange i
don't understand it's like penny lane the
the confusing thing about it strange
okay maybe you shouldn't have snow it
was
what was strange was the firemen rushed
in from the pouring rain now that's
weird yeah god at the very least
to call it strange
i think one time i love that
i want to say one last thing
about this is just just just stay
out in ah is that what the
beatles are trying to say he's telling
drugs channels the problem with these network
each television station that they're not taking
into account the fact that if you
take a risk on someone who's extremely
talented the show will be a bigger
hit than
less than if you just have a
used to send someone who's familiar seeing
like used to seeing and then used
to say movies need movie stars television
makes stars there you go just as
to say that gumby my friend gumby
and his pal pokey too yeah they're
so cute they were cute alright are
we playing this reacher oh yeah shit
but anyway tony okay thank you for
this thank you tony okay for this
suggestion huh bill the sentence beginning with
subsequent letters of the alphabet okay so
this is called so i have to
i have she's called tobar oni
it's called sixty seconds off of it
but do i go and do the
whole sentence myself or no you do
one word okay we do one word
at a time it's like build us
it's like the story but you have
to follow yeah and it has to
make sense and you have to follow
the alpha use the first letter of
the word that you pick okay writing
yeah but shouldn't seven yes give us
a letter letter so you
we're gonna start lorne yeah okay s
are you secretive fuck
a letter is ss somebody stop me
you're out it was my turn anyway
somebody took
yeah ursula's
violin
why
you know okay leaving no letter no
what what w o x w w
f w x okay mark mayor and
want to start over youtube literally said
hey do you mind lucky the gate
today and i said who am i
mark marron and you at bow
ah cool love i love you yeah
why okay so this is where it
gets tough why it's always gonna fall
part of why a guy with a
y is xavier
you
it has to be keeper
oh where's me oh
this is aw okay this is my
ammo i always what horner it is
and i knew yes you just wanna
do it yourself i do it like
yeah chi oh yeah play doha start
the letter is babies can do
for grandma help is
just wow
cheap
women
alright alright alright mommy no oh
please so queen please
oh no please please
ya know i was like wow episodes
i love you know please please rewind
yeah ah something xavi know you're in
like something you lavender very wet
yeah those are the psychic in minority
report just like bloody huge i would
think because you had a high scrooge
like she was trying to wish away
i'd go
i just keep saying words you do
do it alone
it's really fun alright alright what's what's
the letter okay it's a just a
starting enough alright um
any ball
clearly doesn't
exist
for good
course however
of course however i just
kitty
look
i am your father many neurons over
protons
quietly reserve
sanctions therefore
understanding
violence
will
x-ray your
zanzibar's that was really good wow it
was real good if you go and
you have to go a little bit
faster but i feel like i need
a different letters start off so i'm
just gonna say what he's now you
won't that's what he's gonna remember i
said a totally different thing ah okay
um almost
breaking almost breaking could danny he took
a second and then still wait made
no sense almost breaking cadet ever forget
ghosts
i liked this story
almost breaking could danny ever forget he
goes almost breaking content
keep going but is like this is
like news that it was almost breaking
news but a couple of people heard
it already all those breaking canadian burritos
keep going
ha ha ha
i joined clarissa
laughing charisma with a gay yeah with
a k
huh i joined clarissa laughing
many nerds opens
popcorn they opened it they opened popcorn
quietly hey fine yeah you can open
po many nerds open popcorn quietly retiring
saliva he did repeat a couple of
the words yeah it's hard not to
retiring saliva that doesn't make sense
ounce
yours made no sense
then under vaccines where
xanadu
yep zebras
yeah that's how you play sixty seconds
alphabet bow sixty seconds
letters
na jana card and a goddamn wow
janna god
we we ah fun funds so so
such a good time such a good
time so fun such a good time
so fun guys we want to thank
you all for listening to the show
scott needs to know what time it
is i don't what what you just
you're checking your pulse i was checking
my pulse and honestly it's sky high
after this you're saying credit history that
i had i want that right yeah
guys we'd love you guys make us
some freedom mashups you guys give some
remixes and give us some ah
fun dialogue mashups in your remix we're
still waiting on those presence by the
way we never got any presence guys
yeah fuck well we did get the
nice t-shirt knowing it was okay we
got but that was nice to go
on kingpins but we want more present
when he hasn't we want to be
like christmas morning anytime we caught a
tax record an episode where we just
like oh my god
look at bicycle and something each bikes
send us bicycles disease says like a
fun little thing you recently looked out
people with like if there's a scooter
lying around on the street just pick
it up and put it in a
box and send it to oh man
put a bird go to inbox and
it just freedom dash usa dot com
will be like the old times we
used to send fan mail to someone
you're a little kid
kid we said yeah now we're on
health and we just want stuff yeah
you're an adult we're an adult give
us your stuff or are we all
adult for your little cream
don't cream why i have a center's
adult cream sent us creams send us
creams for our genitals this is crow
this angwin send us things that will
make our genitals not age so much
hey i want mom sure i want
my genitals to shine when i'm saying
iman
we gotta go alright gotta go we'll
see you next time thanks to da
chicken and going up
a